i'm just hearing a nadeem sahabi
education circuit ah okay so this was
going back to what i was about to say
about um
about people loyal to boris johnson as
well nadine doris nadim
and mr zahawi have been allies and
supporters of boris johnson for many
years nadine i remember was there when
the prime minister pulled out of the
leadership race in 2016 she was in the
room culture we haven't really mentioned
she was in tears he made her a health
minister when he was made pm and now
he's promoted her to culture secretary
and just as the rts conference actually
in cambridge is underway with all the
media executives there they have been
expecting oliver dowden to give a
keynote speech about what they're going
to do about privatization of channel 4
that's all up in the air now nadine
doris takes that brief and mr zahawi
being given the education brief he will
be delighted about that he was on the
back benches promoted to vaccines
minister and being given a really big
brief there okay and uh just finally
what does this say about the way that
boris johnson wants to take this
government
well i think from the moves i've seen so
far the two things i would say is that
he uh demands loyalty
uh and he has promoted people
uh on the basis of loyalty but also he
has put into key briefs people that he
hopes can actually
deliver what he needs them to do and i'm
thinking in terms of mr zahawi who they
have rated as a vaccine's minister
putting him into education the prime
minister's talked about how that is a
massive brief and it needs fixing
and then michael gove into communities
and housing that's all about the
leveling up agenda
and housing i also think what is
interesting about this reshuffle is the
prime minister has been sensitive to the
fact that in there it sometimes felt
like a bit of a boys club in some of the
subcommittees uh dealing with cavity it
was nearly an all-male cast unless
pretty patel uh got round the table so
now look at how he's changing his
cabinet he's got liz truss and priti
patel two of the four big officers of
state go to women he's put nadine doris
into his cabinet it looks like anne
marie trevelyan is coming back after she
lost her job when the international
development department was merged with
the foreign office so i think that is a
theme as well that he's trying
to make to promote more diversity in his
cabinet all round